[Music]
meet one of instagrams most famous
playboys it was the world driving fast
cars and eating at the world's finest
restaurants he even gets hip-hop stars
like Wyclef Jean to play at his lavish
parties posting his exploits on his
Instagram account under the name Teddy
and Gama
but this isn't your typical Instagram
star he's the vice president of the
country equatorial guinea a small
country in West Africa with a lot of oil
[Music]
though Dora
nagamma Obion is the second most
powerful man in the country his father
is the world's longest-serving president
Teodoro Obiang and Gama the Obiang
family has a massive fortune running
into the hundreds of millions of dollars
but how if they made their money
Equatorial Guinea has some of the most
opaque national accounts in the world
per head it is the richest country in
Africa yet people live in plastic Shack
poverty the most recent figures
available from the World Bank suggests
that three-quarters of the population
live below the poverty line but the
presidential family seemed oblivious to
the poverty una cosa tampoco my father
if the country is so wealthy where is
all the money going I sometimes refer to
a quarter Guinea as the North Korea of
Africa there are no freedoms today a
patrol Guinea has the widest gap between
GDP per capita or income per capita and
Human Development Index access to
healthcare access to water access to
education to to Alicante is a lawyer
from Equatorial Guinea who is an exile
in the United States he runs an
organization that is trying to tackle
corruption in his homeland it is
extremely dangerous for people in my
country to speak their mind about
anything the government deems political
he knows firsthand how the massive theft
of public money has left little behind
to fund public services in Equatorial
Guinea going to hospital is in fact
signing your own death sentence
my sister had a complication with a
pregnancy and she died at the hospital
bled to death because there was no
doctor in sight while most of the
population live in squalid conditions
teddy splashes the cash showing off his
wealth on his Instagram account often
using the hashtag luxury living he
reveals a life of privilege and excess
court papers say he amassed around 300
million dollars worldwide between 2000
and 2011 despite earning an official
government salary of less than $100,000
a year the Department of Justice alleged
that Teddy embezzled millions of dollars
from the public purse as cabinet
minister they discover for instance that
he approaches multi-million dollar
private jet and mansion in Malibu and
then the luxury cars
the Department of Justice agreed a
settlement of around 30 million dollars
with teddy this year teddy has found
himself on trial again at this time in a
separate case in France charged with
embezzlement and money laundering
after being unsuccessful in claiming
diplomatic immunity he failed to show up
to any of the court hearings instead he
posted videos and Instagram of himself
on Safari near Victoria Falls the French
courts valued his assets in France at
around 100 million euros including a
large property bought for 25 million
euros in Paris the French public
prosecutor has asked for a three-year
jail sentence a 30 million euro fine and
all of teddys assets in France to be
seized the vice-president denies the
charges okay the future for Equatorial
Guinea looks bleep the president is
aging and his son is preparing to take
over this is someone that is more
concerned about flushing his cash dam
governing the spendthrift strongmen of
Equatorial Guinea are not the only
presidential family in Africa who were
under investigation for embezzling from
the public purse the presidents of Gabon
and the Republic of Congo are also being
investigated by judges in France but
Teddy's had a busy time of late posting
from the beaches of Brazil to the Great
Wall of China there are plenty of
countries where regulators turn a blind
eye to despots who want to hide their
ill-gotten gains
but their secrets are increasingly being
leaked and it helps if the autocrats
themselves do the leaking via Instagram
[Music]
you